in my head Destiny's here big guest why
don't we bring on
to the I asked the two girls that were
on the tape panel if they wanted to come
back now a little back story the uh
Esther one of the girls on the tape
panel very disrespectful and rude but
good content right so it's like you kind
of
weigh the pros and the cons and you're
like whatever you'll just let her on
whatever okay
[Music]
um so a lot of people ask like why she's
LED on okay guys look at we're trying to
put on a show we're trying to make
content here
and a lot of times you need someone on
the other side that doesn't agree with
you that you can go at it with because
it's not a good panel if everyone agrees